فكر في الأمر كركوب سجادة سحرية
لتناول العشاء الآن ، ربما يكون من
الأفضل ربط برجر الترياكي بحزام الأمان الخاص
به ، مرحبًا بكم في مختبر المدينة المعقول ،
هذه تقنية جديدة
تستخدمها القوات البريطانية على الأرض
منذ العام الماضي وفي الداخل هناك
كاميرا صغيرة ، محرك وبطارية
تسمح لها بالتحليق تمت معايرتها ، ولديها
إصلاح GPS بمجرد
إطلاقها قليلاً ،
فهذه الطائرة هي كارني أسادا ،
وتلتقي بمفجر البوريتو ، الفاصوليا والأرز
من بنات أفكار اثنين من المهندسين في
التقييمات والتوصيات الشائعة
أصدر موقع الويب الخاص بامتياز Domino في المملكة المتحدة مقطع الفيديو هذا لطائرة بدون
طيار تقدم اثنين من البيتزا لمدة 30 دقيقة
أو أقل ، وستشتري شيئًا ما على
أمازون ، وستدخل
ذلك الصندوق الأصفر الصغير
، وستدخل تلك الطائرة الصغيرة بدون طيار وستصل إلى عتبة داركم.
نعتقد حقًا أن السماء هي الحد الأقصى
مع هذه التكنولوجيا ونريد
تحفيز الناس لبدء التفكير في
كيفية تطبيق هذا على
مشاكل العالم الحقيقي